همم
الزياره الاولى لمسؤولين الغربيين الى
اوكرانيا بعد اندلاع الحرب كانت تلك التي
قام بها رؤساء وزراء بولندا والسلوفينيا
وتشيك الى كيف الخامسه عشر من مارس
والتقوا فيها رئيس بلدوميرزنسكي
في التاسع من ابريل رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني انذاك باريس جونسون يصل الى
اوكرانيا بشكل مفاجئ ويجري محادثات مع
رئيس لينسكي ويتجول معه في شوارع كيف بعد
ذلك باربعه ايام وصلت كل من رؤساء بولندا
ودول البلطيق لاتيه واستونيا وليتوانيا
كيا عبر القطار وتجول مع رئيسكي في ضواحي
العاصمه في الرابع والعشرين من ابريل
وزراء الخارجيه والدفاع الامريكيه
الانترنت
خطه لدعم اوكرانيا في الثامن من مايو رئيس
الوزراء الكنديه جاسترو يصل
ويعقد مؤتمر صحفيا مشتركا مع الراي زنسكي
السادس عشر من يونيو الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرو والمستشار الالماني ورئيس
الوزراء الايطالي انا ذاك ماريو دراجي
يصلون كيف في رحله المشتركه لاظهار دعمهم
لاوكرانيا
في الثامن عشر من اغسطس الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يصل الى ليفيرب غربيه
اوكرانيا ويشارك في قمه ثلاثيه مع نظيره
الاوكراني والامين العام للامم المتحده